[Music]
foreign
hello you're watching the Press preview
a first look at what is on the front
pages as they arrive over the next half
an hour we're going to see what's making
the headlines for the contributing
editor for Navara media Moya Lothian
McLean and broadcaster and former
government Minister Anna subri right
let's take a look at the front pages
ahead of Monday morning we'll start with
a Metro it references another name for
nitrous oxide hippie crack in its
coverage of the government's
announcement that it intends to ban
laughing gas in an attempt to tackle
anti-social Behavior
on the front of the telegraph reports
that the prime minister is to launch a
Crackdown on begging as he announces
this war on anti-social Behavior
the express reports that would be
conservative Rebels are urging the PM to
close every legal loophole that would
allow bodies like the European Court of
human rights to quash the deportation of
migrants from the United Kingdom
saying on the subject of migration the
eye has the headline sunac moves to calm
Tory nerves head of crunch vote on small
boats
the guardian has seen an internal NHS
document suggesting that the Health
Service is currently running with 154
000 fewer staff than is necessary to
operate properly and that figure could
exceed 570
000 by 2036.
the times leads with a report that raw
sewage was dumped into rivers and
coastal areas across England more than
300 000 times last year despite a fall
in the overall number of spills
the global edition of the Ft carries a
warning from the international monetary
fund the recent difficulties for banks
around the world are posing a threat to
overall Financial stability
and the star predicts very heavy rain in
the coming days for many of us that has
already arrived
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you are seeing on your screen right
now during this program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us talk about
them
well as I said we're joined tonight by
Moya Lothian McLean and Anna subri and
good evening to you both
um right we're not going to talk about
the rain we might come to that later and
we're discussing that in the break so
much for the start of British summer
time we will start though with uh
laughing gas the ban that's been
announced by the government today it's
on a number of the front pages including
the guardian uh you can see it there on
the right hand column of the front page
um the sale of nitrous oxide or laughing
gas will be banned and and a lot of
people are picking up on this saying
look there are already laws to protect
people from the harmful effects of drugs
like laughing gas
um so this seems to be a headline
Grabber from the government how are you
viewing this is this a good thing or a
step too far
I think it is a headline Grabber I mean
it is quite extraordinary isn't it I
mean obviously Sophie Ridge was
interviewing Michael Gove here we have
it on the front page it's it's on the
front page the guardian he's on the
front page of the Metro as well and this
gas is is going to be banned because
apparently it's part of government
Crackdown on anti-social behavior and
they've obviously sort of looked around
for any drugs that they can possibly
sort of focus on to get this sort of
headline hippie Crackdown because
apparently it's called hippie crack and
you know can you imagine how shocked
this government is going to be when it
finds out that actually it's been in
power for the last 30 years I'm afraid I
am horribly cynical about all of this
and I just think it's a dog whistle
because they have been in past 13 years
I have no experience whatsoever of
laughing gas I I I I've never come
across it uh have you not seen the
silver canisters banana because that's
the sort of sign to people that have
never used it or seen people using it's
the little silver canisters you know in
in the in the drains and in the in the
gutter on roads and you've never seen
them balloons yeah
I mean I I walk through Nottingham Derby
Lincoln and Leicester city centers on a
fairly regular basis maybe I don't go to
the right places yeah anyway it's a
problem
rather than looking down at the ground
um maybe something with Michael Dove
goes and Maria what's your view on this
because the government you know their
advisory Council on the misuse of drugs
that they you know ask for advice on
this they actually advise against new
laws to ban nitrous oxide and saying
that it actually do more harm than good
and a lot of people have pointed out as
I said that there are laws in place to
prevent this we mentioned the silver
canisters it's already illegal to litter
um it's already illegal to produce or
Supply this gas for its psychoactive
effects this would mainly focus on
possession so anyone being found you
know it's the most common one of the
most commonly used drugs between the
ages of 16 and 24. anyone found to be in
possession of this will get a could get
a criminal record
yeah I think what you have to understand
this particular policy in the context of
is why is a sort of Crackdown on what
they call anti-social Behavior we've
seen this before we've seen who it
primarily criminalizes which is young
people people who fall outside of the
social parameters set by whatever
Administration is in charge so the other
story that is in line with this is all
about begging and as part of the begging
story people who present a public
nuisance a who gets to decide that when
begging in public will also find
themselves criminalized and when we see
these sort of policies they ignore the
root causes of what we know as
anti-social Behavior something like
laughing gas Etc young kids gathering
doing this on the street all of these
things are more symptoms of a lack of
spaces to go a lack of structure within
their lives a lack of play you know
places where young people can gather and
hang out so they're forced instead onto
the streets they're forced into doing
these sort of activities in public
spaces and more and more groups that
would never usually mix or coalesce are
finding themselves in the same space and
you're getting this real war between you
know say Young upwardly mobile
professionals and young children who in
previous years might have been elsewhere
and when the government criminalizes
people like children what we see instead
of
um I guess positive react positive
inaction of policies that would perhaps
stop doing laughing gases things like
children falling apart of the police we
had the news yesterday that over nearly
3 000 children have been strip searched
by police in the last four years alone
however half of those took place without
an appropriate adult in place strip
searches for those who are unaware are
so violating and traumatic but the
increase in criminalization of young
people for just being young people is
going to result in more of that
um and I see this policy as once again
the government flailing around looking
for punitive solutions to a crisis that
has of their own making it's 13 years of
austerity as Anna referenced that has
led to this shrinking of spaces where
Young people can go and instead push
them out into the open at the open
streets so what we're going to get from
antisocial behaviors not anti-social
Behavior policies is not a reduction in
what we call anti-social Behavior but
instead the further criminalization of
people who are already vulnerable and
already fall on the wrong side of the
law
um let's move on to the front page of
the eye sunach moves to calm Tory nerves
ahead of a crunch vote on small boats
the government is facing a rebellion by
up to 60 Tory right-wingers who want to
toughen up its Flagship illegal
migration bill as it hits the commons uh
tomorrow uh Anna you'll be on this
well I think this is actually quite
interesting in the sense that sunac is
determined he's going to put through
this illegal appropriately named illegal
migration bill but his his Rebellion at
the moment is not from the more sensible
thing of the conservative party I would
say it's from those who are inhabiting
the nationalists more right well they
are more right-wing part of the
conservative party and they seem to want
to impose every single law that they can
in order to prevent any form of appeal
by people once they've arrived in the
United Kingdom and they seemed that that
is where sunax Rebellion is going to be
not from the more sensible thing of the
party in my opinion the more balmy side
of the party and this is this is a
problem for him uh and he's got to quell
their uh that Rebellion I think he'd
still get his bill
um or parts of it through but they're
going to put forward Amendment which
presumably label would vote against so
he he shouldn't lose those votes but
it's interesting to see that this is
where his focus is going to be is on his
own Rebellion but from that part of the
conservative party and it's a big number
as well I think it's somewhere in the
region of 60 if not more members of
parliament they'll remember conservative
members of parliament I guess on the
front page of the Daily Express Tory
Rebels fight to close migrant loophole
um Moya that's the thing isn't it this
this illegal migration Bill the big
concern about what Rishi sunak and the
Home Secretary want to do with it is
that it won't actually come to fruition
because of the legal challenges and this
is Tory Rebel saying you know you have
to make this tight there can be no
wiggle room we don't want any
interference from any courts
foreign
yeah it's I mean one of the policies
they're trying to one of the Amendments
they're trying to pass is that domestic
courts will no longer be able to block
uh the removal of migrants to places
like Rwanda for example it's just
fascinating that the illegal migration
bill is meant to be referencing uh
irregular migration routes which are not
illegal by the way
um when in fact the thing that it's
trying to do is very very illegal
according to all existing conventions
and agreements we have around the
treatment of refugees and human rights
and what is fascinating is this backbend
Rebellion it will never be satisfied it
will never be satisfied unless the UK
Asylum system is closed altogether to
anyone coming in and when you look at
the policies that they're putting
forward the Amendments they're putting
forward it is nothing to do with a fair
system as Rishi sunak and Zoella
bravaman keep trumpeting it's to do with
completely shutting out any sort of
Asylum claims whatsoever and it's
fascinating for example at the moment
the lack of responsibility that we are
taking Britain as a country country
for migrants coming here for you know if
you look at the largest demographic
currently coming to Britain via small
boats for example it's a it's people
from Afghanistan and this is a direct
result of the UK's failed evacuation of
Afghanistan of the failed mission that
happened in Afghanistan it was
catastrophic I left thousands of people
behind and the promise of safe
immigration routes for Afghanistan
resettlement schemes has just not
materialized the only pathway currently
opened to the UK for afghanistanis is
has managed to just who are not already
here has managed to resettle just 22
people and that also already this number
of people that I could resettle was
about twenty thousand so you look at the
responsibilities we have we're not even
enacting those
um and still we have this back bench
Rebellion this forcible and sunac is
constantly focused on his internal win
the party rather than actually
representing uh a human rights but also
the wider concerns of the country if you
look at the wider population I think
more people care about Healthcare than
they do about people coming on small
boats
front pages of a lot of the newspapers
tomorrow including the times and Anna
the puppet for this Rebellion is
apparently the Home Secretary Suella
bravaman
yes this is again I thought this was a
fascinating take by the times here
because essentially what this story is
saying and this is Whitehall insiders
which again an interesting term because
that means somebody's briefing against
Sue Ella ratherman and what they're
saying is is that she's a sock puppet in
other words she's handing glove with
these Rebels she agrees with these
Rebels and she is working quietly with
them because she agrees with them in
sharp contrast to Rishi sunak and so
it's going to be interesting to see how
all of that plays out but Brotherman is
very hard line on all of this she tried
to make sure that some of these
amendments that the rebels are going to
put forward apparently were in the bill
and she failed there because sooner
doesn't agree with her but again it
shows you the real tussle that is going
on that I thought that was an
astonishing piece of briefing against
the Home Secretary from people within
government and I just wonder whether or
not sunat realize realizes that Sue
Ellen bravaman is is really not fit to
be the Home Secretary Annette Moyet
thank you for the moment that story one
to watch this week is the illegal
migration Bill uh heads to the commons
this week stay with us because coming up
after break we're going to be discussing
drastic NHS staff shortages which could
get even worse in the year to come join
us for that and we'll after the break
[Music]
hello welcome back you are watching The
Press preview uh joining me tonight Moya
Lothian McLean and Anna subri we're
going to head straight back to the front
pages that are coming into us uh here at
Sky News and we're going to go to the
guardian first uh NHS Chief sound alarm
on spiraling staff shortages uh this has
gone in exclusive a call for radical
homegrown recruitment drive to avoid a
shortfall of 571
000 NHS staff within the next 13 years
um kind of the shocking thing about this
is that perhaps nobody is surprised by
these numbers
yes
well I don't know I mean actually that's
an extraordinary figure so anyway the
the Guardians got hold of this
long-awaited Workforce plan uh which
still hasn't been published but the
guardian has got a hold of it and the
figures are quite extraordinary we we're
going to have a shortfall of 28 000 GPS
for example and it's 44 000 shortfall of
community nurses and then in 30 by in 13
years time over half a million
effectively vacancies so this is a this
is just in NHS England by the way this
is not doesn't include Wales to Scotland
as well so it just shows you the the
real challenge that rnh has
um in both the retention of Staff but
most importantly recruiting staff in the
numbers that we need and what the
guardian also says
um that the report is um saying is that
we can't rely on two things one oversees
people coming from overseas to work in
our NHS personally of course I think we
should be great if we could have some of
those EU workers back but we can't
obviously fill these sorts of gaps with
people from overseas and the second
thing which they say which is really
important is is that these this is going
to cost us a great deal of money and
we've got to put that Finance in in
order to meet these shortfalls
uh lawyers there's a recent draft of the
player reveals that the NHS is already
operating with 154 000 fewer full-time
staff than it needs far more than the
124 000 official figure the NHS is
already operating you know far below
expected standards in terms of being
able to work efficiently properly and
safely
yeah I think this is part of the wider
crumbling of the NHS which links in also
with the lack of political will to
actually full-on address the crisis So
within this report there's also uh an
interesting tidbit about oh alleged war
between Jeremy Hunt's Treasury and Steve
Barclays Health Ministry where Barclay
is willing to spend the money but Hunt
is not that it would take to train up
these homegrown staff instead of
spending billions on training up Temp
and bringing in staff from overseas or
temporary staff
um but it seems in the short term
there's this will to sort of patch up
nowhere near that we need to try and
make up the short film in private
agencies in private in private staff and
agency staff
um I think in 2022 in labor party foi
revealed there'd been a two point no 4.6
billion spent on agency doctors in the
last five years and you know at least
five grand spent for single agency
doctor ships so there's this willingness
to spend on the short term but there's
not this willingness to fund the NHS
with one big
um Splurge of billions perhaps because
of how the Optics would look to the
conservative base
um and because of that it's just
creaking along and ever more parts are
falling off so we're going to see this
continuing until that political will is
there to actually address the crisis in
the way it needs which is funding for
staff
um let's just take a look at this story
inside the Metro um it's a bit of story
that's been around all day today and
this is the former Health secretary and
a former Chancellor asking for 1500
pounds per hour for advisory work
outside their jobs as ministers and Anna
this is particularly bad timing when you
think of the cost of living crisis and
the story we've just been talking about
when you've got Junior doctors who are
on 14 pounds an hour asking for 19
pounds an hour and you've got two
ministers here in full-time employment
on three figure salaries asking for 1500
pounds per hour it's not good is it
it's not breaking any rules I should say
it's not bringing any rules but it's not
a good look no it isn't
it
but you're absolutely right it doesn't
actually Break The Rules I mean members
of parliament can can do those second
jobs they can charge whatever amount
that they want to
um I find it extraordinary that those
two particular people think that they're
that they are worth 1500 pounds an hour
I mean it's just extraordinary you've
been there Anna should the rule on
allowing second jobs
should that be ripped up should
that not be allowed or is there a
credible case arguing that the MP can
have second jobs why do they need them I
think I think there is I mean I never I
had a second job but there are some
members of parliament for example that
there's a labor Health Minister who
works shifts in a e I don't have any
problem with that at all I think it's
fantastic Rosanna brings real experience
yeah absolutely Maria Caulfield who's a
health Minister she works as a nurse
um and does shifts there and then there
are people who write Rachel Reeves has
written the most brilliant book looking
at women the politicians uh there's a
wonderful biography at the moment about
Harold Wilson written by another
politician I don't have a problem with
that member I don't have a problem with
that and of course because the ultimate
test is what your your electorate things
your constituents thing and ah it's
difficult to see how quasi-kartang is
going yeah I just wanna I just want to
bring a moisture for a quick word on
this because Moya from the outside
looking in what's your view on MPS
having second jobs
I think when the second jobs rule was
brought in it was a very different
context than it is now and he's done a
huge salary and the abuse of second jobs
has been manifest so I think for now
there should be scrapped okay good to
hear your thoughts and Anna as well and
I'm making a good case for some second
jobs that are meaningful and add
something uh others do not more I think
it should be a total ban uh thank you
both very much indeed